hey y'all it's andrew koch here and in
this tower tuesday video we're not going
to be looking at this week's data set
instead i wanted to start a series where
i focus on learning neural networks
specifically using the keras library
um the reason why i like keras over
using things like
tensorflow or pi torch or in this case
torch
is because i like keras's like
interactive or more
um uh uniform interface i think keras is
kind of like the tidy models
of neural networks and additionally
keras actually
is the front end of tensorflow so you're
you're basically using tensorflow but
you have a much more simplified
interface so i
thought one interesting video would
to be using the lscm text generation
um example and i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna write out the entire text
generation
model instead i'm just going to use
their direct example and use our own
data for it
i think this is kind of a good idea um
because that way we can focus more on
getting some intuition of like
what we're actually trying to do or how
do we even load this data into
a neural network to actually generate
text
so with the text that we're going to
generate is some trump
uh trump tweets i thought it was kind of
interesting to
do your own um text and since there's a
trump twitter archive
i downloaded all of trump's tweets um
since yesterday
so uh let's open up
my our markdown file and i actually
already
pasted everything in so i figured this
video would
mostly be a walk through instead of
actual coding but i think that's uh
pretty important and
it's a good introduction to the main
ideas of neural networks
so i'm just going to load in my packages
uh in this case we're gonna load in
keras uh tidy verse and tokenizers
so keras is obviously the package for
our neural network architecture that
we're gonna be building
issues we're gonna just use tidy verse
because i wanna use um some
stringer and do some data manipulation
stuff to the text and then we're going
to use tokenizer which is actually going
to
convert our table of text into
a list of text and one thing with neural
networks is you're basically doing a lot
of
list manipulations so you're gonna be
using like a lot of like s apply
um mapping functions etc
so we load in our uh libraries i'm gonna
load in our text and our text is
actually
pretty clean it's just one column full
of
text so what we're actually gonna be
making
is a character level uh text generation
model
so i'm gonna do some basic regular
expression cleanups so
for example this thing right here is
gonna eliminate most of the links
um right this command will make it into
lower case
and then this command right here is
essentially removing anything besides
a lowercase letters a period or white
space
and then also use this to remove the
dash end and dash r
so if we actually run this part
we can see that we basically removed all
the weird numbers and we just have pure
letters and spaces um
i then will pull the text which will
basically grab all his text and convert
it to a list
i'll use scr2o just in case i did
anything crazy
and then i'm going to basically collapse
it um using the dash
n and lastly it's going to tokenize the
characters
so it's basically split all of these
sentences into letters
there'll be a list of letters for every
uh observation
we're going to run that okay
we can print that and we can see our
corpus length is
what is it million 780
000 um uh tokens long
i'm also going to use it grab the text
and grab all of the
um unique characters and this will
essentially be
our uh our character library or
dictionary that we're going to reference
as like an index
we're also going to specify the max
amount of characters that we're going to
be using
so in this case i'm going to say 15
characters so we're going to use 15
characters
for our model um
the next thing right here is basically
the main idea of how we're going to make
a text generation model
so this looks kind of confusing what
it's essentially doing
is it obviously with the the comments
it's cutting the semi-redundant
sequences
to the max length of characters so
essentially what it's doing is
it's taking these um these words
or these sentences uh taking 15
characters out of it
okay and then taking one character out
of it at the end
and then uh having it predict that
character
so i'm going to run this additionally
it's going to do some data manipulation
so we can do more vectorization to it
so the x character will be the
number the characters that we're going
to use and then the y
is the next character that we're trying
to predict and this will basically
convert it to ones and zeros
using our dictionary so i'm gonna run
this
and hopefully i won't run into any
memory constraints a big problem with
actually doing neural networks is
basically trying to figure out
what type of data we can uh how we can
manipulate the data
so it'll fit into a neural network
neural networks essentially want
zeros and ones or anything in between so
i'm gonna show you just a basic
little intuition of what we're trying to
do using matrices i'm actually gonna put
my
our markdown thing to my left just so i
can keep track of it
okay so this is basically the matrix
that we're using
so we have 15 characters that we're
using and then
for each character we have these
characters that could be in this
position
okay so this is essentially the
dictionary and we're based saying
okay so if i were to type in like
the and then b space
cat you know et cetera et cetera
it would essentially be like ones and
zeros so it'd be like a one would be
right there
uh oh the rest would be zeros a one
would be right
uh here so it kind of reminds me of like
was it the uh like itbs or the bubble
sheets right the bubble sheets where
you're
taking your midterms so using these like
essentially one hot encoded uh
vectors or matrices we're basically
trying to predict what's the next
character which will be
this single little list
so that's basically what it's doing and
um using neural networks it'll basically
say
okay we've seen the cat i'll say like
is um and we'll say
s m a l
so it's saying like the cat is smal and
then what we're trying to predict is
l right this is what we're trying to
predict so it'll basically use this
um train it it'll say okay well our next
character should have been an l so we'll
go back
and we'll reshuffle again and keep on
trying to predict it so it's just using
these past letters to
predict the next letter okay
um i think our thing uh completed so
let's actually create our model
so in this case we're making a uh
basically a single layer
lstm model so we initialize our
keras model and we start adding our
layers
so this is our first lstm layer um
we're going to say that our input shape
is our max length
by the length of characters what this is
essentially saying is
what we want what we're inputting
is this so it's saying it's 15
characters
by our total dictionary or total
available characters that we could
even use right so it just has this
little matrix that we're trying to throw
into it
and even though this is like essentially
a
uh two-dimensional matrix right because
it's not like a list
it's a square um what's cool about
neural nets is
networks is they can use um
multi-dimensional matrices so
unlike shallow black box models where
it's essentially taking
tabular data or essentially a list of a
list of data so it's thinking like okay
we have
this and we're trying to predict that um
the major
the uh neural networks can take
two-dimensional three-dimensional
or even four-dimensional and up so
uh we're just saying like this is what
our entire
input is which is like the available
characters that we're trying to do or
like the one-high encoded matrix and
then we're saying
we want uh our output nodes from this to
be 128 nodes
then we're doing a final layer which
will be our output layer
and this output layer will be the
available characters that we're trying
to predict
so let's say okay so what's the what's
the probability that the next character
is in a
what's the probability of it being a b
etc
so that's why our last layer has to have
the output to be
the length of our characters or the
total amount total number of unique
characters we can
use or predict then we use a softmax
activation function which is basically
how it can compute that
probabilities we have an optimizer which
is optimize our rms prop
um generally people will use atom
when they in this case the example just
uses rms prop
and then also use some regularization
lastly when we compile it we use
categorical cross entropy and that's
what we
and this is the loss we use for
multi-class classification
if you were to do a specific binary you
do like i think binary cross-time
entropy etc
so now let's actually go to these
functions that they added
so first we have this sample mod
function
and with this what these functions
essentially do
is that they're trying to use a random
letter to feed it into the model
and then using that model to uh to
predict another letter
and then it takes those two letters and
puts it back into the model to predict
predict another letter so it's kind of
this recursive sequence where it's
essentially
predicting uh using that prediction as
an input and predicting it again
so with this uh temperature basically um
if we can look at it temperature
essentially um affects how
how variable the predictions are and
uses like our multinomial distribution
multinomial distribution to figure out a
random number to use
as the uh input
as the input and outputs of the letters
and then on epic or epoch n uh it's
essentially gonna
train the model and then for every epoch
or epic
it's gonna basically run the sample mod
function
and generate some text for every time it
runs
i actually did forget the last model fit
so let's do that
so we're going to run that and now we
can just paste this in
and run it so i'm just gonna oops what
let's print callback not found oops i
forgot
my print callback which should be that
so i'll throw that in right there
and then it's gonna start training also
cool is it might be thrown out a plot
sometimes
but i guess it's just going to do this
so right now
uh when we're fitting it we're fitting
using the
input text data or input like matrix
that's uh essentially the one hood one
hot encoded uh two dimensional vectors
and then we're trying to predict using
one list which is
the available letters that we can
predict we're using a batch size of 128
so essentially we're just using 128 um
tweets
and then we're letting the model uh look
at it letting it
learn what it's supposed to be
predicting and then we're going to send
another batch
it's going to keep on doing that until
we basically went through our entire
data set
so in this case we have about thirty
nine thousand or forty thousand
uh tweets so it's going 128 of the
40 000 tweets training it and going
through it
one time and as you can see uh it's
going through it pretty fast
um i we so i'm going to wait a little
bit
but i figured i also could go over a
little bit more about
keras and some research resources that i
really like
so for example keras is pretty
straightforward they have a lot of great
tutorials
the the best tutorial probably or the
biggest intro tutorial is the
fashion data set or the mnist data set
um i've actually made a video on doing
the the uh
the mnist data set where you basically
classify your handwritten numbers
but the but rstudios tensorflow
on page is a pretty good guide about
learning just
you know how to do neural networks
specifically with um
transitioning from like your traditional
usage of data frames to tensors
additionally i would also recommend a
deep learning with
r by like francois chole
which is actually the creator of
um keras so he has a great book
about how to use r and also the
intuition between all these models so
not only just doing your simple neural
networks but also getting into
convolutional nets
um lstm nets recurring neural networks
etc
um i will
say that um when do you actually use
neural networks is dependent
on your use case which is so i would say
that
um generally if i'm looking at like say
the penguin data set
i won't really go into neural networks
because neural networks seem to be
overkill
you also need a lot of data for it and
it doesn't add that much business value
besides
just only predictive power a good use
case for neural networks is with
things where you need to create another
off features so things like
uh images images um are very hard
for black box models to understand
because you have high dimensionality
because when you're looking at images
you're essentially analyzing every pixel
and it's that pixel value so it can be
rgb
and in that case neural networks are
great with high dimensional data
and uh they're good at creating uh
basically features that we want to
understand
like curves additionally um sometimes
neural networks are really good with
highly imbalanced data
so if your data if your class that
you're trying to predict
is like 99 in balance where 99 of it is
negative
one percent is positive and neural
network would be good at
um would be good for that problem
specifically auto encoders
and i really want to make some more
videos on neural networks
so i'll probably make a video on auto
encoders soon
but auto encoders are always the thing
that i think about when we have
you know high class imbalances and a lot
of data
so using auto encoders for sensor data
for anomaly detection
is basically i'm one of the main uses
for them
let's see here so i'll probably uh uh
see i'll probably uh stop the video and
resume it when this
model is done uh fitting
okay so the model finished
training and we can see uh the generated
text
so for example it uses a diversity of
0.2
and we can see the communities and
democrats and the democrats are the fake
news is the democrats and the last night
of the democrats are
starting and the country and the many
with the etc so you can see how
um most of this doesn't really make any
sense but it's pretty interesting
because
it's honestly making something that
resembles
like an understandable sentence and it
and if anything we can understand
you know what are the words that he's
using a lot that this model is kind of
like learning off of
so as we increase that diversity we can
see that the words are
are more diverse right so we'll be all
too bust at the present real middle big
people to be and has live
so you can see it's getting a little bit
more um
diverse but it's a losing a lot of
the actual uh readability of it and then
we can see it
keeping uh it's still going and it's
basically just gibberish so things that
we could actually improve
off of is just running it more time so
if we increase the epics or epochs
we could probably get a more legible um
more readable
dialogue i also uh have this uh
function that i found off of i believe
um i think julia silly's website
so this thing this function will be
using our model to generate phrases
so let's actually go through it um
generate phrase
it uses a model a text a chars
so i'll give it model our text
our chars our max length and i think it
gives us our
was it our diversity i think
generate phrase diversity so diversity
is equal to let's say 0.5
so we can see you generate
and it's going to take a while because
it's recursively trying to predict on
itself
but that'll take a little bit so all but
will be in the people and should be
assigned to the
be so starts to the documents so it's
talking about documents
i was going to be talking about
democrats let's run it again to see if
we'll generate a
new text
yep so it generated some new text and a
support out to rombers and
press good mini president in the country
and the democrats
etcetera so this model can definitely be
improved
uh by running more epics
so you may also be wondering like why
don't we just use a word level model
and that's a pretty good um question the
main id
the main issue with word level models is
that
you are dealing with a larger array
of words than letters so since we're
only using letters there's only about 26
to 28
characters that we're going to be using
because we're including spaces periods
and maybe even
commas and apostrophes so at max that's
about
30 um 30 characters that we're actually
going to be having to
remember um opposed to
actually using tokens or words we can
see how it can expand
a lot because generally people use a
relatively
diverse amount of words so that could be
ranging from a thousand to five thousand
words
when you have that your matrix gets very
large
and additionally you're gonna start
running out of memory
so since we're actually creating these
data sets and storing it in memory um
our your computer or r can't exactly
handle these data sets because they're
too large
which really kind of leads us to how can
we handle um data sets that come
that fall out of memory and that's how
that's what basically leads to
batch um batch training where you're
essentially gonna um
take a little um chunk of the data
run it through this little uh
pre-processing
pre-processing stage then giving to the
model and uh keeping
and keep doing that until we went
through our entire data set
or one epic or epoch
so that's one problem with using a lot
of these word level models is that
character level models
are generally easier to implement
because we have
less dimensionality issues
and what's interesting is character
level models are pretty good at
basically
creating somewhat understandable
sentences
or in words see for this we never gave
it words we only just gave it
um the letters to predict and was able
to actually make um
some pretty good understandable words
and honestly
some pretty good uh sentences so i know
this is a pretty quick video
and i know we didn't do a lot of coding
at least for myself but i think this is
a pretty interesting thing to do just
kind of doing a code review
of the keras example so i'll see you
guys next week and tidy on